- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
In this video I'm going to tell you about
a piece of punctuation called the colon.
The colon is these two
little dots right here,
one stacked on top of the other.
And it has quite a few functions,
just like a lot of other
pieces of punctuation.
The idea of this linking function
is that the colon can link
an independent or dependent clause
with another independent
or dependent clause,
or a phrase, or a word when
there's a strong connection
between the two things that it's linking.
So if I want to tell someone what I think
about two movies about
animals, I could say:
Both movies are great,
but Sky Pal has one thing
that makes it better:
dogs that play sports.
This is one sentence with two parts
that are linked with this colon.
So the first part says,
both movies are great,
but Sky Pal has one things
that makes it better.
And that could stand alone as a sentence,
but it doesn't tell us
what that one thing is.
So the colon comes in and tells us,
I'm about to tell you what that thing is,
dogs that play sports.
So in this case the
colon just sort of serves
as a connection between the
purple part of the sentence
and the yellow part of the sentence.
Another example is something like:
Going skydiving made me face
one of my greatest fears: parachutes.
Right, again this colon is
sort of linking these two
parts of the sentence where one answers
an unanswered question
from the first part.
Like, what is this greatest fear?
Well, it's parachutes.
The colon is here to link between
this whole independent clause
and the word parachutes.
I could just as well say
going skydiving made me face
one of my greatest fears.
That's a perfectly fine sentence.
But without a colon linking
to what that fear is,
that sentence just kind
of leaves us wondering.
So another sort of subset
of the colon's ability
to link things is that
it can introduce things.
One thing that the colon
can introduce is a list.
I could say:
We needed to find three more
items on the scavenger hunt:
a four-leaf clover, a cauldron,
and an abandoned ship.
The second thing a colon
can introduce is an item.
If I'm talking about the other day
when I had a weird legume
craving, I could say:
I only wanted one thing from
the grocery store: peanuts.
Lastly, a colon can introduce a quote.
My friend Liz says it best:
"Never open a jar of
pickles you can't close."
I'm not really sure what that means,
but she does say it best.
So, as you can see, like it
was in the first couple of
example sentences, there's
kind of information missing
from the first parts of all
three of these sentences.
We needed to find three more
items on the scavenger hunt.
Well, what did you need to find?
Or, I only wanted one thing
from the grocery store.
What did you want?
Or, my friend Liz says it best.
Well, what does she say?
That's were the colon comes in,
to introduce that missing information.
So there's one final case
of the linking function
of the colon that I want
to get into in this video.
If you remember from the
beginning of the video,
I said that colons can
introduce an independent clause
to another independent clause sometimes.
That's pretty rare.
Usually that's the job of
a comma and a conjunction,
or maybe a semicolon.
But, as always, it's still
important for you to know
even the things that don't
happen all that often.
Something like, remember
to take off your sunglasses
when you drive through a tunnel:
you can't see when it's that dark.
The colon in this example
shows that, you can't see
when it's that dark is
an explanation of why
you need to take off your sunglasses.
This is one of the two types of sentences
where it makes sense to have a colon
between two parts of the sentence
that could stand on their
own as individual sentences.
So we can say, one, the second
part explains the first part.
The other case is when the second part
of the sentence is emphasized.
So this would be something like,
I drank way too much soda: I'm
never going to fall asleep!
These are two independent clauses
that could be their own sentences,
but they're closely related enough that
it makes sense to have
them connected as one.
So the colon links them together.
And the second part is emphasized, right?
That's the focus of the sentence.
I'm never going to fall asleep!
So in these two sentences we can see
that the colon can connect two parts
that can stand alone as
their own sentences, right?
Whether it's two independent clauses,
like in the second sentence,
or an independent clause
that's technically connected
to a dependent clause
but can stand alone.
Now okay, this usage is really uncommon.
I really want to stress that.
Usually when we're uniting
two independent clauses,
or at least two parts of a sentence
that can stand on their own
as individual sentences,
we're gonna use a comma and
a conjunction or a semicolon.
But in the case that the second clause,
or the second part of the
sentence is emphasized
or explaining the first clause,
then you'll want to use a colon.
Just keep that in mind.
Usually this independent to
independent clause linking
happens with a semicolon and not a colon.
But regardless, this is important to know.
It's possible in these specific cases.
What's most important for you to take away
is that the colon can link things
and introduce things as
part of its many functions.
And that's the linking
function of the colon.
We've got independent
clauses, dependent clauses,
phrases, words, and introductions
for lists, and items, and quotes.
You can learn anything.
Paige out.